[Music]
wild card activated to meet a man right
there it's roughly 10:00 a.m. Eastern
Standard Time and the tap man guitar is
whispering to you through a mounted
microphone on the other end of the
computer screen morning evening
afternoon but I hope you're having a
good one dude we're having a good one
bud better wake up
he's categorised himself under the just
chatting section on Twitch you saw my
nipple we're just chatting okay I'm
sorry
Tim's flanked by his plush sidekick
Kevin the penguin and his voice is soft
and conversational like the way your
co-workers talk to you by the coffee
machine in the morning none of my
friends play overwatch so I had to pay
five bucks to tell someone hey you just
wasted your money lull in chat as Tim
finishes his last full cam conversation
you can hear the menu screen music from
fortnight blend in seamlessly not going
to pay the skin today my life Tim's
first game of the day sets the tone and
that usually means a series of
unfortunate bouts with fall damage and a
light peppering of flame from his chat
this randomly came to mind but when I
turn on your stream I instantly started
chanting Tim Tim he's our man if he can
take fall damage no one can but Tim
rounds into form after a few games
usually Martha
he knows his way around a green shotgun
after he gets into the swing of things
[Music]
[Applause]
just in time for his chat to pipe up and
let him know that his day-to-day
companions in the fight for fortnight
glory are online almost every day you
can count on some combination of these
three streamers to squad up and
fortnight together to fix him
you gotta scoot all the way back dude
really Jim is literally that stares dude
oh my god it's too perfect
stupid they've all got their own team
drama
archetypes ninja the cool guy with the
biggest gun always swooping in for a 2k
that saves the day Lupo the supportive
yet sometimes toxic friend who stays
calm cool and collected at all times and
then there's Tim maybe not as fast
skilled or charming as the coolest kids
at school but with a heart of gold
[Music]
together they form a super team of sorts
a streaming partnership that has led to
astronomical growth for all three of
them this growth is something that
almost never gets brought up on stream
most of the air is filled with in-game
comms and ninja taking the odd fat joke
jab at Tim Styles I think everyone
should stop directing fat jokes that's
him he's not enough on his plate but if
you take a close look tim has risen to
be one of the most prolific streamers to
which hostile this is his story Tim I
had my one tattoo my professor was doing
Roy said Tim I raised my hand
he was like Tim the tap man that's how I
got my head Tim the tap man began his
streaming career in late 2013 and
focused primarily on call of duty black
ops 2 black ops 2
from the beginning Tim was always an
entertainer first although back then he
was even more wild than he is today from
day one it was very clear that Tim had a
brand and we don't mean the tattoos
Tim's life lessons for real dude use
your head don't be an idiot this is what
I tell all my kids that I work with you
you're the things you do have great
impacts on you
Tim's goal was to create the kind of
atmosphere where everyone who clicked
into a stream felt welcome another
reason that I scrape is because I love
people I my job as you guys know I work
with at-risk kids and I've always been
in interaction with people throughout my
whole life and just learning to
appreciate relationships a lot there was
no gamer who was too new or uninitiated
to hang out in his channel brother the
range of conversations has no bounds
what do you call a blog between two
brunettes a mental block some streamers
rise to prominence on the back of their
skill or popularity as a pro okay well
okay we're on a good lead got the
weapons
[Music]
others do it by putting on a show
then there's Tim he isn't outlandish or
toxic and he doesn't wear a wig or put
on a persona he's just in it for a good
time and he's not concerned about making
a few mistakes along the way that's all
part of the show and boy does he own it
I am the worst Call of Duty player in
the history of this game I just want to
win just one gun fight Lord Jesus just
one Tim the tap mainstream group pretty
steadily early on he didn't make any big
splashes or blow up overnight but as
early as August 2015
Tim was streaming to more than 6,000
viewers at a time those numbers
continued for much of 2015 and 2016 as
he built his community and developed his
YouTube page but I'm a streamer and my
chat was say hi how I shut this bucket
this is my chat even early on Tim wasn't
shy about allowing the community he
built to take a peek behind the curtain
at their protagonists life so I'm gonna
show you guys what everything is behind
the scenes of my actual computer and
what actually streams everything up here
we have the webcam his fans learned
about his love for Jeeps the origins of
his tattoos so the second tattoo is the
bear lion eagle the legal and which
sports teams he rooted for where my
Blackhawks had obviously Blackhawks play
today got to represent you know
during his early days as a streamer Tim
primarily played call of duty it was his
bread and butter and served as a nice
backdrop for the community he had built
nice he saw only one but on May 26th
2016 Blizzard released their modernized
version of the class based shooter
overwatch an elite international task
force charged with ending the war and
restoring Liberty to all nations
overwatch the hype surrounding the game
was through the roof and Tim jumped on
board I'm doing it this transition
between games was a big deal for Tim's
popularity unlike many of the top
streamers it's not always the gameplay
that attracts viewers to his channel in
an escape from the norm his audience is
not tied to any one specific game get me
now zombies eyelids build more by the
time 2017 rolled around and he was
streaming overwatch full time tim was
streaming to an average of more than
14,000 viewers
see the charts do you see that little
thing he was quickly becoming one of the
faces of the game and while all the
games best players were focused on
competitive play he was one of over
watches most popular streamers I'm
killing everyone hog dead sim dead
during his time playing overwatch Tim
often played with other big names in the
community like xqc and seagull
I spy the game since then he's always
prioritized streaming in groups and
although a lot of streamers often team
up with friends while online it always
feels a little more pronounced on Tim
stream these teams are not I think these
are okay play I can play a couple hits
can listen excuse e we want to win I
watched you play trace for the other day
on your street it was like I was
watching someone on ice skates one of
the most unique parts of his
relationship with overwatch was the
relationship between his skill level and
his love for the game
[Laughter]
that's waitin food he reached the
highest ranking milestone possible in
overwatch Grand Master I mean that's
about where I was I guess I placed
higher than Seagal and he was doing it
with skill intensive characters like
Genji and McCree but as he got better
his love for the game dissolved my
Twitter right now is blowing up because
I made a tweet about overwatch and why
I'm not playing it anymore
yeah so the combination of the sometimes
toxic nature of high-level team games
and the stagnancy that was the overwatch
dive meta drove Tim the tap man to
explore other options for history are
you I always get charged always I always
and just as Tim was exploring looking
for a new game to share the spotlight
with fortnight was quickly becoming the
biggest game on the planet there's Tim
the tap man there he is
there's Tim they were a match made in
heaven
fortnight this morning of course what
else is there - FM stream
nice fortnight became the biggest game
on the planet almost overnight and along
with its rise the twitch ecosystem
vaulted some of its most beloved
streamers up the charts with it when the
boom first hit it was ninja who became
the undisputed king a fortnight on
Twitch let's go I thank the thunderous
token
oh yeah yeah let's go
but every hero has their sidekicks and
Tim the tap man was that for ninja shoot
it in 3 2 1 now armadillo using
completed over the fortnight frenzy has
been unique for building personalities
on Twitch the game is so fun social and
evocative that it's allowed its biggest
advocates on Twitch to really build
their personality around the game early
on sure Tim was one of those guys that
would squat up with ninja on stream but
ever since then his stream has grown
outward we did it between April and May
2018 Tim's average viewership sprung
from over 15k to more than 21 K at a
time he began streaming outside of his
core group of squad partners and joined
the likes of Nick mercs and cloak see on
stream here and their dad take you
second your right
yeah just telling me I got a push to
Sadat to push the talk you shouldn't
have to
yes damn teeny and my buddy had for
twenty one two three so twenty kill game
gingy
since then he's managed to keep this
over twenty thousand viewer average and
spiked in July with more than twenty
eight thousand viewers at a time Tim
also managed to make one of the scariest
jumps out of the fortnight era after all
trying to maintain your viewership while
playing other games is no easy task
watch this chat I want to see why you
sub to this channel right here Tim's
dabbled in Call of Duty blackout has
streamed his overwatch placements and
even maintained solid numbers during the
just chatting portion of his stream you
saw my nipple we're just chatting okay
I'm sorry please you saw my nipple too
this is the end we had a good run chat
we're not just chatting anymore dude oh
god more recently he's even broken the
mold for a twitch streamer he's become
the face of the National Football League
on Twitch
Tim's done multiple sponsored streams
for the NFL during their Thursday Night
Football twitch broadcasts for tonight
dance no during those games Tim was able
to meet and surpass his average twitch
viewership doing something completely
unprecedented for someone who plays
video games for a living
over the course of his transition to
fortnight Tim the tap man has made huge
strides when something is as
all-encompassing as this game there's
always going to be risk in branching out
work but Tim has flourished didn't get
him he secured an identity that
transcends the games he plays and
sometimes even transcends games at all
this may be his single greatest strength
you can old Kevin hostage for now he
needs subs impacts spiked that fat bird
for not giving us the subs Hey
once again Cham just listening to the
best hear or I do that's what you get
he's not as popular as twitch royalty
like ninja or shroud take the games away
from Tim and there's something left
standing even if it is some
self-deprecating jokes
[Music]
it's 11:30 p.m. Eastern Time and Tim the
tap man just took fall damage again
Kevin is sitting in the glowing green
monster fridge behind him because
someone donated $15 to ruin his day
that's my cat everyone say hello to my
cat Evan Tim just cracked a Miller Lite
all right first of all up to the sheet
from the stream for my chat for your
Chad do you want during them that my
ladies are you putting yourself in
harm's way no no it's not hard I had
in game he's wearing his signature
tomato head skin a style he claimed as
his own after the addition of the tomato
temple to format island where you now go
to worship Tim tears the cheek I can't
please you gotta run some fun for
tonight congrats keep up the work hey
thanks cheapest hey keep up the streams
by the way dude
thank you for your 10 only bless + bless
the tomato Awards he's leaving for
twitchcon in the morning where he's
committed to trying to meet absolutely
every single person who wants to meet
him
90% of the women around you are taller
than you a tall order for someone with
45,000 subscribers but that's who he is
[Music]
and at twitchcon that personality we've
grown to love will be put on display for
thousands at the roast of Tim the top
man Tim you look like a troll doll
pencil topper that was stung by a bee
you look like a rejected member of a
lesbian biker gang the streamer that's
bigger than any game he chooses to play
chant you can't say we lost this okay I
gotta give us bibblethump with the
[ __ ] wings on them let me hear Boise
nothing else okay I'm cool okay my dad
agrees okay
lookit now now he's gonna go tell his
friends he's gonna add a day of his life
dude you know what I'm saying we just
changed his whole day the kind of guy
who will take the time to let twitch
chat into his life or a baby
the impregnate are you for real yeah
really yeah there's a gift and a great
guy and I'm just so glad for him and
what's happened to him is just amazing
and he's good at his trade to celebrate
his first child's gender reveal live
[Music]
he's got nothing too hot I will be
talking about my faith in this if that
is going to offend you or you know what
I want to continue to watch this video I
will not push it on you you are feel
free to exit out now tomorrow when you
wake up you can count on him being there
a large gamer whispering into a
microphone about his stuffed penguin and
thousands watching to support him the
tap yes
thanks for watching if you want more
great content just like this be sure to
hit the subscribe button
[Music]